with an ongoing incident in glasgow city
center sky news understands that
six people have been injured following a
stabbing attack in the city center
including a police officer
whose condition is described as critical
but stable the main suspect in the
attack a man
has been shot dead by police forensic
officers
armed officers and emergency services
are at the scene
which centers around the park inn hotel
eyewitnesses have told sky news they saw
people being taken on stretchers
out of the building armed police could
be seen entering a building but
investigators say they're not looking
for anyone else
in connection with the incident a police
cordon remains in place on west george
street and the public
are being told to stay away police
scotland said in a statement
i would like to reassure the public that
this is a contained incident and that
the wider public
is not at risk armed police officers
attended the incident and i can confirm
that a male
suspect was shot by an armed officer
i would like to reassure the public that
at this time we are not looking for
anyone else in relation to this incident
i can also confirm that a police officer
was injured while dealing with the
incident
and that officer is receiving treatment
in
hospital we do understand that that
police officer is in a critical
but stable condition let's speak to sky
scotland correspondent
james matthews who joins me now from
glasgow james what is the latest there
well it's still a busy scene here as you
can imagine it happened just about
10 to 10 to 1 o'clock this afternoon
i'll step out of shots so you can see
the park in behind me many emergency
services vehicles
police here in force of course if you
can see that double decker bus about 100
yards down the street
just beyond that you can see the white
facade
of the park inn now this is a hotel
that's been used over the past few
months
to house refugees and asylum seekers who
have been decanted
over the course of the coronavirus
pandemic
what happened according to one person
that i've spoken to who was inside the
hotel
he said he was sleeping it was ten to
one and he heard screaming
male screaming female screaming he was
on the third floor
he said he headed towards reception via
the lift
now the elevator he said was covered in
blood when he got out into the reception
area
he saw a male receptionist behind
reception
who had suffered an injury was covered
in blood and was gasping for air
he said there was a second male
receptionist who was on the
exterior steps of the hotel and he
similarly was injured
and was gasping for air
thereafter what happened was the police
were called
armed police officers turned out in
force
and the perpetrator was shot dead within
the building in terms of the confirmed
figures we have
there is one dead and that is the
individual who was wielding the knife
there are six people in hospital they
include
a police officer whose condition is
described
as critical but stable
yeah and in terms of the response to it
as we saw those images
james a short time ago of the armed
police
responding to it uh entering the
building
and a large police presence there now
what can you see
yeah let me just um this is we're live
david we're live uh i apologize for
putting you on the telly live can you
tell me what's the what's the state of
play at the moment
at the moment jim we have one person
dead we have six other people in
hospital
uh i don't have their conditions
and obviously inquiries are ongoing a
police officer amongst the injured as
well
as one of them okay what can you tell me
about him i don't have any information
just now we'll update you as soon as we
can